hi i enjoy call of duty
i have for years in my time at gamespot
i've made dozens of call of duty related
videos
and it's easily the series i've sunk the
most hours into
so i had the bright idea of revisiting
every call of duty in 2021
all of them all of them
the call of duty series has been around
for nearly 20
years and it has changed but if you're
like me
you haven't experienced all of these
changes because they haven't played
every single call of duty
well that's what i'm here to do it's me
you
and every call of duty played in 2021
if you like where this is going drop a
like and buckle up because
here we go before the bombastic rise to
fame
before all the talking online matches
and before the millions and billions of
dollars
there was call of duty one released on
october 9 2003
this was an exclusive pc title tailing
the success of the world war ii
resurgence from the late 90s and early
2000s
a needle in this haystack was infinity
ward's very first game
at this point they were a brand new
studio with fewer than two dozen
employees
but little did they know that the work
they put forth in the coming years would
lead to something bigger than
anyone could have imagined by today's
standards call of duty 1 seems like a
humble timestamp of the early 2000s
its presentation isn't over the top
characters don't speak in one-liners
and the gameplay is familiar even to
something like call of duty 4 which
wouldn't come around for years
if you grew up playing fps titles on pc
you'll understand what i mean
every game around this time sort of
looked like this which made call of duty
1 very approachable to someone like me
who had never played it
playing this for the first time in 2021
right away a strange case of nostalgia
kicked in for me
the familiar voice acting of steve bloom
mixed with the warm tones of the outdoor
training yard
really transported me back to a simpler
time hey is that captain price
it is for the most part the controls are
familiar too
but the biggest and immediate difference
is that there is no ability to sprint
and that sort of sets the tone for this
entire experience it's literally a
slower paced game
something i strangely didn't anticipate
as far as the narrative this was the
start of a lot of storytelling elements
that would carry over into other call of
duty games
for example the story is told through
three different campaigns
american british and soviet within these
stories there are big set pieces that
are utilized more than once
or even through the duration of the
entire level you get a compass with your
directives
and the friendly ai won't push the
enemies until you do the story is told
through mission briefings at the start
of each level
they're packed with information about
your mission but since most of them are
nothing more than a slideshow it can
kind of come off as homework
i should be paying attention but i want
to play already in each mission you take
on three or four objectives and usually
regroup with your squad in between
the call of duty formula we're all used
to started right here
things like picking up weapons off of
enemy soldiers aiming down sights for
improved accuracy
and utilizing grenades to clear out
hotspots are all here
i didn't play this game originally but i
knew how to instantly
and that just proves how well infinity
ward established the basics
almost all of the core elements of a
call of duty game are presented here in
this very first installment
and because of that i felt comfortable
starting with this game i played on the
hardest difficulty for what i think is
the truest experience but that might
have set me back a little bit because
sometimes it felt like more of a grind
than a fun world war ii game
in the end however i can't deny the
impact this had and its significant
importance on gaming as a whole
this is simply the beginning we lost the
captain
damn that was a very fine man
before dlc's were even called that
expansion packs were offered to players
for added content like new levels
weapons and more
call of duty was no exception it was a
pc game after all
so in late 2004 its first and only
expansion was released
call of duty united offensive this
expansion is broken up into three
smaller campaigns
once again the us british and soviet
some of the new levels were pretty large
and a few new guns were added
but it's more of the same for better or
worse but i have to say i wasn't
expecting an airplane battle so early in
the series it was a great change of pace
same for the gunboat mission they also
added a sprint feature
which really aided my playthrough it's
almost silly how different call of duty
games are without it
i felt like i was actually playing a
call of duty game and not some other
world war
ii fps of the era speaking of which i
think playing call of duty and its
expansion back to back the way i did
may have taken away some of its magic
back in 2003 let's say you finished the
first call of duty and you were just
waiting for more
how excited must you have felt to hear
that an expansion was on its way
i'm positive the anticipation made this
expansion's release
way more memorable i think i just goofed
up
one thing i haven't mentioned yet is how
tons of sounds carry over from these
first few games
getting hit and losing your hearing your
players sprinting and vaulting noises
and even some ui sounds were reused it's
weird but it's comforting
little things like this begin to form
the groundwork for what makes a call of
duty game
a call of duty game so really my
memories with this game are a mix of
endurance
patience and things blowing up all
around me overall it's a nice addition
but in true
expansion pack fashion it felt like more
of the same
[Music]
originally released for the playstation
2 xbox and gamecube
call of duty finest hour was the first
call of duty game on console
it goes without saying that this was a
smart move and would greatly affect the
future of the series
later games would continue this trend
and launch on multiple consoles and also
share their release with pc but since
this one's for console only
finest hour carries a different tone in
its visuals it's darker and murkier
thanks to the renderware engine but i
think it works to the game's advantage
you see what i mean in the game's
opening mission which takes place at
night
the glowing fires and explosions in
stalingrad look great on older hardware
but besides the visuals the storytelling
is embellished with small touches like
multiple camera angles individual
narratives before each mission
and ending cutscenes that close out the
missions the gameplay itself isn't bad
but has some sensitivity issues when it
comes to the analog sticks that really
can't be tweaked
but this was a time where first person
shooter controls on consoles were still
working out the kinks
so i got used to it eventually the music
by michael guilloccino
is wonderful and it isn't always blaring
out of context like in other games
and stressful moments like when you're
down in the sewers it slows down to fit
the level just
perfectly
even though the mission objectives are
similar to the first call of duty the
pace felt smoother to me
i didn't spend hours trying to get
through one level like i did before
and if missions were getting a little
stale stuff like this always helped
break it up
these little cutscenes are such a thing
of this era and i always find them
charming even when they're only like
three or four seconds
the cinematics also help you give
context as to who you are
you're not just a faceless soldier this
time you speak and contribute in more
ways than before
like call of duty one you also play
three campaigns serving the soviet
american and british forces
but it feels less like a playable
history lesson than it did before
while there are historical briefings
before each mission finest hour
introduced more of a personal narrative
with each campaign
these are voiced over wonderfully and do
a great job of connecting you
to the character you're playing as other
games like medal of honor did this too
and it really helped me hit the restart
button in my mind before each mission
overall i think finest hour is a solid
introduction to call of duty on console
it was the first spin-off title but it
certainly wouldn't be the last
two years and 27 million dollars after
call of duty won
we got call of duty 2 in 2005. jumping
into this game i noticed loads of
similarities to call of duty 1.
many assets are reused most notably the
weapons and sounds
at a glance this actually looks like
another expansion of the first game
however beyond that first glance i
noticed more and more details
textures and player models are polished
and the voice acting is still charming
but improved
and there's more of it on my command
kick open the door and frag those crowds
ready now the overall gameplay is
similar too
but they took away the sprinting option
which i found to be a major setback
you can't sprint or even throw back
enemy grenades but
hey at least captain price is back you
know i actually learned all about this
at e3 2019
art director joel emsley discussed how
modern warfare 2019 would see the return
of captain price
and that wasn't the first time that it
happened infinity ward wanted to utilize
price again
so they did he leads the troops in the
british campaign and even rocked some
steven irwin shorts
as far as the storytelling goes i feel
like call of duty 2
took some small steps in the right
direction there are more memorable
characters you go into battle with
and the missions themselves are a little
more personal that way you start to
remember faces and voices and get a
sense of brotherhood
like call of duty 1 your missions vary
from holding out areas until help
arrives
fighting off reinforcements and counter
attacks and of course
taking down aa guns but again in the
regular infantry missions
things get a little repetitive
especially voice lines
speaking of sound work this game is loud
i had everything turned down almost
all the way and it was still a mess of
screaming explosions
loud weapons and the music
later call of duty 2 was ported to the
all-new xbox 360.
and even a spin-off title called call of
duty 2 big red one
surfaced on playstation 2 and gamecube
in my mind this was actually an
important distinction from the first two
games
it was developed by gray matter studios
and treyarch and while it looks a little
rough around the edges
it's an impressive departure in
storytelling and gameplay
in real life the united states army's
first infantry division
also known as the big red one was a
renowned group
the game's entire campaign spotlights
the infantry's efforts throughout world
war
ii like before visually you can tell
this game was intended for consoles
and i don't mean that in a bad way the
textures are gritty and even a bit hazy
but it felt like a breath of fresh air
compared to the sharp stark textures of
call of duty 1 and 2.
the voice acting is exciting the sound
mixing is better and the story is mostly
told in game
which keeps the pacing nice and swift
you're dropped into a variety of
missions including ground
tank and even air combat it's quite
impressive compared to previous titles a
lot has changed for the better here
i think the standout difference might be
the dialogue between you and your fellow
soldiers
they share wise cracks and talk in a
natural believable way
but they also express fear and have
conversations that aren't about the
troubles that lie ahead
compare this to call of duty 1 and 2
where the ai squad mates are only good
for continually spawning in and dying
this was the first time in the series
where i cared about my entire team and
that's huge
all around this was a great departure
from the main series and a great first
call of duty title from treyarch
fortunately activision felt the same way
and treyarch got to develop call of duty
3 for the following year
when call of duty 3 launched in 2006 i
still wasn't a call of duty player
i was probably still obsessing over
kingdom hearts 2. however
it was the first mainline sequel that
didn't get a pc release
which didn't go over too well with the
pc community things like mod support
custom lobbies and better graphics just
weren't an option this time around
on the flip side of that coin it had a
great sales run on console and sold more
than 2 million copies in that year
even getting the old platinum hits
treatment on xbox speaking of which at
this point
yours truly still wasn't quite into the
next generation of gaming
either but this game was causing a buzz
for some of my friends and co-workers
who were playing online
most of them were waiting for halo 3 but
they were enjoying their time with call
of duty's multiplayer
as soon as i booted up this game in 2021
i got big red one vibes with better
graphics
like surprisingly good the textures are
detailed and the environments are really
full
and it just sort of reminds me of
something like call of duty world at war
a game that wouldn't come out for years
while it's nice to look at i was
honestly dreading another world war ii
game
funny enough despite how well this game
did i learned that a lot of people
around this time were also sick of world
war ii games
on top of the five other call of duty
games i just talked about more
developers were flooding game shelves
with their own world war ii games
so yeah i can imagine how repetitive
that might have felt
but anyway i knew there weren't many
more down the line so i buckled up
and i prepared for war one last time
just kidding
the game begins as expected you're in a
makeshift military base preparing to
fight when suddenly the fight is brought
to you
and speaking of action this game's
opening mission is full of it
as you battle your way through the city
of saint louis in france you're forced
to jump
crawl call in airstrikes and even fight
this dude in a quick time event
which i think was the first in the
series it was a standout level for me
especially because afterwards
next few levels feel like i'm replaying
call of duty 2 again
there's only so many times i can clear a
house or destroy aa guns
fight off a german counter-attack but
again since i played these games back to
back that might just be on me
aside from all the shooting there are
loads of explosions and background
effects that can be pretty immersive
compared to the huge and stark
environments of the earlier games
i felt like every stealth mission i
played ended up in a firefight
right down to the last few levels which
are the most action-packed
i also remember starting a lot of
missions that just begin in a gun fight
you can't wait around or hunt down
objectives when they come to you instead
it really pushes the game along but it
was a little grueling without the
gameplay breaks i came to expect
the action is probably my biggest
takeaway from this entire game
good action with sparks of good
storytelling and unfortunately we take
one big step backwards before that
all changes
[Music]
you know i almost didn't mention call of
duty roads to victory
because it's a very simple offshoot of
call of duty 3
on the psp i don't think this was meant
to be a runaway success in the psp's
library
more so of a way for activision to test
the waters on the psp
platform visually it reminds me of a ps1
game with its blocky reused character
models
and its foggy limited view of
environments
aside from being a little stale in its
objectives and some dopey ai
there's nothing really wrong with this
title well the controls are pretty
busted i'll say that
as far as the actual game there are 14
missions between the american canadian
and british theater and in true psp
fashion they're about 10 minutes each
a solid amount of weapons are
represented but world war ii staples
like the m1
thompson and mp40 were getting a little
stale a problem i fear from the start
the music and voice acting are all just
fine in fact it's always a treat to hear
different voice lines from other
companies that aren't infinity ward
we need to link up with them follow me
overall this is a watered down version
of call of duty that i don't think i'll
revisit
but i'm glad i gave it a shot for the
sake of this video
50 000 people used to live here
now it's a ghost town 2007 starts an
important chapter in call of duty
as well as my life infinity ward was
back
and instead of looking at previous words
for inspiration they decided to use a
modern setting
on november 5th call of duty 4 modern
warfare was launched on all home
consoles
and pc at this point i was in college
and had purposefully held back on
picking up an xbox 360.
one i was broke but two i knew i would
get sucked in
so i considered it a favor to myself and
my studies
regardless more and more of my coworkers
and childhood friends were hopping on
xbox live
and telling me that i needed to check
out cod 4 cod 4 cod 4.
excited and reluctant i bought a used
360 from the nicest dude on craigslist
he barely got around to using it and
sold it to me with the original box
and even the receipt i booted it up and
everything changed
call of duty was officially a part of my
life faster than i got to know my xbox i
was obsessed with call of duty 4's
online multiplayer
like many others i love the fast paced
shooting variety of weapons maps and of
course
the [ __ ] talk but when i finally decided
to load up the game's single player mode
i was
not let down replaying it this year was
refreshing
the story and its characters not only
hold up but are still just as dynamic
and fleshed out as i remember
i always found it funny that every
character is taller than you
but i realize that this may have been a
tactic used to make these characters
actually feel larger than life that's a
great way to describe the story too
taking place in the modern era this was
the biggest departure from the call of
duty series yet
this of course meant a huge overhaul of
weapons tech
and environments but the changes didn't
stop there
the tone of the storytelling shifts
dramatically thanks to the modern
setting
and the more bombastic story in world
war ii titles prior
you played through real-life events from
the second world war
in call of duty 4 you play through a
fictional modern story
dealing with terrorism and nuclear
warfare the story felt more like a movie
and had memorable characters like the
returning captain price
and imran zakhaev as one of the main
villains like before though
the narrative is told through multiple
perspectives that contributes to a
grander plot
you still feel like you were a part of
the events but not in a leading role
instead you made room for the heroes
that surrounded you and led the way
like price griggs gaz and others
fighting along these soldiers feels like
you're only proving that you're worth a
damn
and that sort of kept you on your toes
around this time i remember hearing
rumors about how infinity ward worked
with
actual military people when it came to
things like weapons and motion capture
well years later i'm happy to report
that all of that was true
it was the first time the studio worked
with motion capture at all
so to make sure they did it right they
worked with the us marines on everything
from mocap to the smallest detail in the
soldiers weapons and gear
i think this attention to detail really
paid off for the team
and with the stronger iw 3.0 engine
the devs were really able to make this
game shine with all new
lighting effects sound design and
general polish that they couldn't before
over the course of two years infinity
ward worked tirelessly on what would
become one of the most successful
and one of the most important
first-person shooters of all time
it also kicked off the decline of world
war ii games dominating shooters
but activision wouldn't fully realize
that for a few more years
call of duty world at war was almost one
of those wrong place at the wrong time
sort of games
after an astounding success with modern
warfare a world war ii game may have
felt like a step backwards
but personally i hold this game high for
many reasons it was the first call of
duty game where i got the full
experience from launch day
and even before that with the beta world
at war was an all-new story that departs
from the first three titles
it had some standout voice acting from
gary oldman and kiefer sutherland
and a dramatic soundtrack by composer
sean murray
when i replayed it this year i unlocked
a lot of fond memories
the campaign is another good example of
hold your hand storytelling
you're once again led by strong figures
like sergeant roebuck
and victor reznoff and right away you
notice that the storytelling has shifted
dramatically
in a personal more intimate direction no
more
transatlantic narrations or historical
newscasts
instead we see how the war directly
impacts you and your squad
don't remember in the opening mission
you play as private miller
trapped in a prisoner camp ready to be
killed after watching private pyle gets
slaughtered right
in front of you sergeant roebuck and
company come in and save you
only after stabbing everyone around you
then of course it's weapons free
and you're able to take back the island
guns a blazin when i think of this game
i think of standout moments like this
the intro on making the first time you
meet reznoff and of course
the grand ending where the soviet union
takes berlin
and ends the war
[Applause]
playing it again felt familiar and
nostalgic it uses the same infinity war
3.0 engine but with some more
enhancements
you notice lush details in the forested
areas and even more advanced lighting
effects
and at this point i know what you might
be thinking i can't talk about this game
without mentioning one of its biggest
draws
a separate mode that debatably outshines
world at war entirely
nazi zombies created as a side project
during the development of world at war
zombies mode was originally unlocked by
finishing the campaign
the developers were messing with
character models and other bits from the
game files and created a mini game
outside of the main storyline
no voice work no massive story just a
survival mode featuring the undead
when the mini-game was unlocked to the
public at launch fans were
all over it and instantly begged for
more
and boy did they get more zombies mode
turned into a juggernaut
one that is alive and well to this day
more than 30 zombies maps have been
added across
call of duty titles it's become a
subculture of call of duty with its
massive
twisted storyline years of character
development
and integration into the greater call of
duty lore
and we have world at war to thank for
all of it
seriously this topic can be its own
video and if you'd like to see something
like that
let me know with the thumbs up there was
also a ps2 version which is the exact
same game just on older hardware
[Music]
[ __ ] call of duty world at war final
fronts
is an anomaly unlike other cross-gen
call of duty games that are just ports
final fronts is almost an entirely
separate game
it's a t-rated version exclusively
released for the playstation 2.
it borrows names locations and even
voice actors from the original
but a majority of the campaign's
missions are different and of course
tone down in the opening mission instead
of watching sergeant robux slaughter
everyone and save your ass
he trains you in a cod 4 style obstacle
course
but after that at least you're thrown
right into the action on the solomon
islands
obviously the graphics take a hit here
but it takes even more steps back with
the gameplay
and general identity when it comes to
the gameplay
the controls are nowhere near as smooth
as what had been established in cod 4
which brings me to my next point who
decided to port this over to the ps2
and why didn't cod 4 get the same
treatment oh my god
as you progress early on you quickly
discover what makes this game hard to
enjoy
the ai is doofy the gameplay chugs
aiming is weird
and kiefer sutherland's character is
actually modeled from call of duty 3's
dixon
it's not the worst call of duty on this
list but why it exists i'll never know
i'm also secretly bummed that zombies
mode wasn't included
seeing a crappy ps2 version of the
earliest zombies maps might have made me
smile
but hey i can always play that on the
wii
[Music]
and just like that we are halfway there
if you're enjoying my journey so far
drop a like and tune in for part two
because we're going to kick it off
with a little sequel i think you may
have heard of
you